[Music]
yeah we met on a short called eyeball
Eddie mm-hm and it was about a kid with
a glass eye that was your first acting
performance in film I guess you could
say right yeah yeah yeah yeah I I grew
up out here so I did things here and
there but that was the first thing that
I got to like that and then the pilot
for Freaks and Geeks happened right
around the same time right at the pilot
became famous pretty quickly and then oh
yeah everyone saw everyone saw freezin
gates 20 years later it's probably the
biggest cult thing that ever happened
and I did more for your career but
probably over the last uh you know what
in some ways and I think in other ways
it would have been maybe detrimental if
the only thing I had done like if seven
years later eight years later the only
thing that I had done was that I'd it
would have been much harder to break out
of that you know it's good news is that
if that makes if you weren't a dick
probably on set because Judd Apatow
started casting you so you didn't really
know what Judd Apatow was gonna do other
than Freaks and Geeks he hadn't really
done much other they produced a lot I
mean but he actually been a part of a
lot of great things like what I'm not
saying
Ben Stiller show I mean his his
producing resume is massive but I'm
talking about like he blew up after
Freaks and Geeks I mean knocked up all
these other movies that came out it just
I think was really knocked up that said
it or four year old virgin right that
was first 40-year old version was
version the 40-year old version of four
year old virgin diya which comes out in
27 years that that movie I think really
exploded his people's awareness of him
yeah you were a nice guy in the said he
liked you obviously there was probably
some people said that were a little
trouble that didn't work as much maybe I
was trouble you are you're a pain in the
ass they're all trouble do you think he
didn't like if you have kids but one
person he didn't like one person Apatow
didn't like on that set if you had to
think about it it wasn't James Franco
was that man well because he put him in
a lot of stuff didn't he yeah but I
don't know that that I also don't know
that that necessarily dictates the way
people people's working relationships
work weirdly I always find it confusing
when you meet someone who and I'm not
gonna get into a name game on
but when you meet people who are who are
difficult and they and their careers
aren't hurting because of that does that
make sense I think this is a business
where and perhaps any business where you
really sought after it just kind of
depends on the individual and people
will kind of take what they can
business-wise and suffer the
consequences in other